انه اصدر تعليماته برد سريع على تعرض
القوات الامريكيه في شرق سوريا لهجومين
منفصلين ليله الجمعه بالصواريخ والمسيرات
الانتحاريه لكنه اكد في المقابل ان بلاده
لا تسعى لصراع مع ايران وكان المتحدث باسم
خلف الهجمات وهو ما نفته ايران متوعده
بالرد على اي هجوم ضدها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم سياق الهجمات
الاخيره على القوات الامريكيه في سوريا
ومن رسائل التي تحملها ومن اي طرف
واي نهج تعاملت به واشنطن ازاء هذه
الهجمات وما الذي يقوله عن استراتيجيتها
في التعامل مع التصعيد في المنطقه بشكل
عام بالنظر الاتهامها المباشر لايران
باعتبارها مصدر التهديد وانطلاق المسيرات
وهل سيتفاقم الوضع اكثر بعد هذه الهجمات
ام انه عابر ومن الممكن احتوائه
كذلك ما دلاله حصول الهجوم بعد يوم واحد
من اعلان واشنطن نقل اسلحه متقدمه من
الشرق الاوسط الى اسيا والاستعاده عنها
باسلحه اقل تطورا ومنعكاساته على الاقليم
بشكل عام وعلاقه واشنطن به بشكل خاص
[موسيقى]
ليله وصفتها وسائل اعلام ايرانيه بالساخنه
قالت ان القوات الامريكيه المتمركزه شرقيه
سوريا عاشتها بسبب هجمات بالصواريخ
والمسيرات الانتحاريه طالت قاعدتي حقلي
كونيكو والعمر النفطيين لم يتاخر رد الجيش
الامريكي من خلال غارات على مواقع
ميليشيات المحسوبه على ايران قال التقارير
انها خلفت قتلى بين صفوفها ومع ذلك اكد
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان بلاده لا
تسعى لاي صراع مع ايران نتابع جانبا مما
قاله
تحدثت الى فريق الامن القومي وامرت برد
فوري فنفذت القوات الامريكيه غارات جويه
في سوريا استهدفت المسؤولين عن الهجوم على
افراد قواتنا لا تخطئ فهمي ودعوني اؤكد
هنا ان الولايات المتحده لا تسعى الى
الصراع مع ايران ولكن كونوا مستعدين
لضرباتنا القويه لحمايه مواطنين
الرد الايراني جاء عن طريق مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني الذي قال ان اتهامات
واشنطن للطهران بالهجوم على قواعد امريكيه
في سوريا غير صحيحه واضاف المجلس ان
مهاجمه القواعد التي انشات بطلب من
الحكومه السوريه سيتم الرد عليها
[موسيقى]
هذا الموضوع معنا من الكويت الدكتور عبد
الله الشايجي استاذه العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الكويت ومن الدوحه معنى الدكتوره
فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في مركز
الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في الشان
الايراني دكتور عبد الله دكتوره فاطمه
اهلا بكما فيما وراء الخبر ابدا معك دكتور
شايجي طبعا نحن لسنا بصدد حرب كلاميه
تتغذى على التصريحات والمواقف نحن ازاء
مواجهه مسلحه وان كانت محدوده في الزمن
والرقعه الجغرافيه في اي سياق يمكن ان نضع
هذه المواجهه
تحياتي لكم اخت ليلى وكذلك للدكتوره فاطمه
والمشاهدين الكرام وكل عام وانتم بخير
عليكم شهر رمضان يعني يجب ان نفهم القراءه
الايرانيه لما يجري التصعيد هو ايراني
وليس امريكي ايران تقرا اربع اشياء في
موقف الاداره الامريكيه اولا تقرا بان
الملف النووي تراجع بشكل كلي تريد ان
تعيده
ثانيا ايران تريد ان ترسل رساله انا
بالرغم المصالحه والتقارب مع السعوديه لا
يتزال عندها اوراق يمكن ان تستخدمها
لتاجيج الاوضاع ثلاثه ترى بان اداره بايدن
ضعيفه منهمكه بالحرب في اوكرانيا كليا
وتواجه الصين في مواجهات مفتوحه ثلاثه
ايران ايضا ترى بان الجمهوريين يحاولون ان
يحاصروا
بايدن خلال الاسبوعين او 12 يوم الماضيه
او الاسبوعين الماضيين كان في محاولتين في
الكونجرس بمجلس النوا المساله لانهاء
التفويض لاستخدام القوات الامريكيه في
الشرق الاوسط وسحبها من دول الخليج ومن
العراق ومن سوريا فشل ذلك بشكل قياسي قدمه
النائب الجمهوري المتشدد جيتس وحصل فقط
على 103 اصوات وثلاثه
كذلك قدم السناتر الجمهوري ايضا المحافظ
راند بول مشروع ايضا لسحب انهاء التفويض
لاداره الادارات الامريكيه منذ بوش الابن
الى الى بايدن لسحب القوات الامريكيه ايضا
من الشرق الاوسط وايضا كانت خساره مذله له
سته وثمانيه صوت ضد مشروعه ايران تقرا كل
هذه اذا جمعناها معا تقرا ايران ذلك
المشهد بانه في ارتباك في امريكا في عدم
اهتمام بالشان الايراني بالملف النووي
الايراني وتريد ان تذكر الامريكيين بانها
يعني عندها اوراق يمكن ان تؤذيهم تزعجهم
فتحرك يعني الميليشيات المواليه لها في
شمال شرق سوريا وبدات بمهاجمه القواعد
الامريكيه هذا الهجوم هو الثمانين الذي
حدث فجر يوم الخميس وفجر اليوم الجمعه 80
مره
الميليشيات المواليه لايران والحرس الثوري
هاجموا القواعد الامريكيه
والمسيرات ايرانيه كما قال الامريكان
وكذلك بصواريخ ايرانيه والنتيجه ان سنجد
نرى تصعيد واداره بايدن وبايدن شخصيه من
كندا ارسل رساله واضحه لا نريد صراع
ومواجه مع ايران لكن سنرد بقسوه قتله 19
شخص
ضربت مواقعهم الدكتور لا يريد الصراع مع
ايران
هل ايران تريد هل ايران تريد الصراع مع مع
امريكا هذا هو السؤال بماذا ننفذ دكتوره
فاطمه
الصمادي مبادره هذه الميليشيات بهذه
الهجمات ولم نسمع تعليقا رسميا من طهران
حتى الان عليها
دعينا نعود الى العام 2020 بعد اغتيال
قاسم سليماني اعلنت ايران ان هدف الرئيسيه
لها هو اخراج القوات الامريكيه من المنطقه
ومنذ ذلك اليوم وحتى الان ايران لم لم تقل
ولم تعلن انها تراجعت عن هذا الهدف بل
تعيد التاكيد عليه من فتره الى اخرى تماما
كما ان الامريكان والاسرائيليين لديهم هدف
ايضا معلن وهو تحجيم النفوذ الايراني
واخراج ايران من سوريا لذلك هذه الاهداف
المتبادله من يريد ان يخرج القوات
الامريكيه من المنطقه ومن يريد ان يخرج
ايران من من سوريا هي ربما تكون المظله
الاساسيه لهذه المواجهه هناك هدف اسرائيلي
امريكي بتحجيم النفوذ الايراني الاقليمي
بشكل اساسي وفي سوريا على وجه التحديد
لذلك هناك خطه اسرائيليه نشرها معهد
واشنطن كانت تتحدث عن ان استهداف
الميليشيات صحيح ان هذا الهجوم بادرت به
المليشيات لكن علينا ان نتذكر انه في
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه جرس اهداف اكثر
من موقع لايران او لحلفات تابعنا لها ولا
يمكن الفصل في المواجهه في سوريا بين
ما تريده اسرائيل وما تريده الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لذلك التعزيز الهجمات
في سوريا باستهداف الميليشيات ياتي ضمن
خطه تقول بان تحجيم النفوذ الايراني
الاقليمي لا يمكن ان يتم الا
باستهداف حلفاء ايران اما
يعني تقديم امتيازات لهم
وجذبهم بعيدا عن المعسكر الايراني واما
بجعل هذا الحلف مع ايران مكلفا سواء على
صعيد الارواح او على صعيد حتى المكتسبات
الع والسياسيه ولذلك فمن وجهه نظري ان هذه
المواجهه ليست جديده وانما تاخذوا بعدا لا
يمكن عزله عما يجري في المنطقه لا يمكن
عزله عن
السعودي فقط
الرد الايراني الرسمي جاء متاخرا بعض
الشيء بعد تصريحات كثيره من الجانب
الامريكي دكتور شايجي
ذكرت 80 هجوم منذ عام 2021 على
الميليشيات هذه في شرق سوريا والسؤال
والذي ربما المحت اليه ووضعته ضمن
السياقات التي ذكرتها هل الهدف فعلا هو
دفع الولايه المتحده للانسحاب من سوريا
كما حصل في العراق
لا طبعا يعني هناك في سرديه يعني قاعد
نبالغ فيها البعض خاصه من يرون بان امريكا
بالفعل متراجعه منسحبه الروس متقدمين
الصين الان موجودين وقاموا بمصالحه او او
بمفاوضات ومبادره
تفضي الى اعاده العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران يعني كل هذا قاعد يصير في الحديقه
الاماميه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومنطقه نفوذ امريكا لن تنسحب من المنطقه
امريكا عندها اولويات مختلفه اذا قرانا
الوثيقه الامن الوطني ووثيقه الدفاع
الوطني لصدرت في اكتوبر الماضي نرى بان
امريكا تتراجع في المنطقه ما يسموها
يعني تخفض من عديد قواتها وارسال طبعا
امريكا
قبل يومين وكنت الجزيره ايضا تكلمنا عنها
اللي هي ارسال
قاتله الدبابات بدلا من اف 16 واف 15
لتوجيها الى الى
لمواجهه روسيا في اوكرانيا ومواجهه الصين
في شرق اسيا ولكن امريكا لن تنسحب امريكا
تؤكد انها موجوده ان اليوم يبلغ قليل صرح
يعني مسؤول في الكويت
القياده العسكريه الطيران الموجوده عندنا
في الكويت في قاعده عسكريه جويه كويتيه
بان امريكا موجوده عندنا الفين عسكري
امريكي في القاعده الجويه وموجودين لدعم
الامن والاستقرار امريكا عنده 35 الف جندي
وعسكري في دول الخليج وسوريا في 900 وفي
العراق 100000 امريكا موجوده في سوريا
لشيئين لاستمرار في عمليه مقاتله تنظيم
داعش ودعم حلفائهم الاكراد على الارض
الذين
يحرسون عشره الاف مقاتل من داعش موجودين
في سجون يشرف عليها امريكا مع حلفائهم
الاكراد فامريكا لن تنسحب ايران تعلم ذلك
نحن نعلم ذلك الاولويه اختلفت صارت مواجهه
روسيا والصين والشرق الاقصى واوروبا ولكن
الوجود العسكري الامريكي لا يزال كما هو
تقريبا الاولويه تغيرت
ولكن امريكا عليه ان تطمان ايضا حلفائه في
حاله من القلق خاصه بعد انسحاب امريكا
المرتبك والفوضى ومن افغانستان
اثار الكثير من علامات الاستفهام حول جديه
الحمايه الامريكيه او التحالف مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لهذا السبب نرى دول
الخليج قاعد توسع من
حلفائها القوى الكبرى ولكن لا الحلفاء
القوى الكبرى روسيا والصين وحتى الهند في
المستقبل عندهم القدره لملء الفراغ ولا
لتعويض الوجود الامريكي وامريكا لن تنسحب
لان الاقتصاد العالم يعتمد على الامن
والاستقرار في منطقه الخليج وكذلك كما
يشكر الامريكي
اشرت اليه دكتور في الخليج والذي ذكرت
ايران اكثر من مناسبه وقالت انها سياسه
معلنه يعني لايران انها تريد طرد هذه
القوات من الخليج ولكن الحديث الان عن ما
يجري اليوم في ايران هل نحن بصدد ايران
موحده في موقفها من التفاهمات مع واشنطن
ام ان هناك فعلا يجب النظر الى ان هناك
جهات مختلفه
ربما كان لها الراي في الموقف الذي حدث في
سوريا والطريقه التي تم بها توجيه الضربه
دكتوره فاطمه
هذا النوع نظري ان مجلس الامن القومي هو
صاحب القرار على هذا الصعيد ومجلس الامن
القومي في ايران ممثل في ممثلين عن الحرس
الثوري والحكومه والقياده العليا في ايران
هو الذي يعني ياخذ على العاتقه القرار
بشان هذه المسائل صحيح ان ملف مثل ملف
سوريا هو ملف من ملفات الحرس الثوري بصوره
اساسيه لكن اذا كان الحرس الثوري هو الذي
قرر فهو لم يقرر بعيدا عن المظله السياسيه
الاساسيه التي تقرر على هذا الصعيد خاصه
مع هذه الحكومه لا يوجد هناك نوع من
الفراق السياسي الذي كان موجودا في عهد
روحاني بين
الحرس الثوري ووزاره الخارجيه على وجه
على سبيل المثال نحن نتحدث عن نوع من
الانسجام السياسي في القياده في ايران هذا
اليوم
لا يمكن ان نقول بان هذه هذه الضربه اذا
تمت تمت بمعزل عن قرار سياسي بهذا الشان
طيب لننظر الى ما يحدث من تطورات السياسيه
وميدانيه بين طهران واشنطن على انها لا
تعني فقط هذين البلدين وانما تعني غيرهما
من دول المنطقه خاصه اسرائيل في هذا
السياق اجرى هيئه الاركان رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه للقوات الامريكيه مارك
ميلي محادثات عبر الفيديو مع نظيره
الاسرائيلي
وقال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
في بيان ان المسؤولين العسكريين بحثا شؤنا
امنيه اقليميه فضلا عن التنسيق
لمواجهه تهديدات ايران في المنطقه
اذا دكتور عبد الله يعني عندما ننظر الى
هذا الحديث بين الرجلين في وقت يعني حساس
جدا خصوصا ان اسرائيل على مدى سنوات
استهدفت
ميليشيا ايران في سوريا عده مرات ولكن
تجنب الرد الايراني ان يكون في اسرائيل
لانها تعرف تماما مغبت ذلك هل ما يجري هو
استهداف ربما للولايات المتحده
نوع من البديل الان
ورساله ورد على استهداف اسرائيل
يعني دائما طبعا يجب ان نربط اسرائيل
اسرائيل عندها يعني هدف واضح اعلان عنه
ونتنياهو عند عودته قال انه ما يمشن عودته
هي بالدرجه الاولى لمنع ايران من ان تصبح
دوله نوويه يعني كان ملفت يوم الخميس
الماضي تصريحات مهمه في
الاستخبارات الامريكيه ووزير الدفاع
الامريكي ورئيس هيئه الاركان مشتركه خاصه
الجنرال ميلي بان ايران بحاجه الى اسابيع
لتجمع ابنيات كافيه من اليورانيوم المخصب
والبلوتونيوم وخلال اشهر يمكنها ان تنتج
اول قنبله نوويه يعني هذا التحذير او او
هذه هذا التقييم من
اعلى قائد عسكري امريكي الجنرال ميلي رئيس
هيئه الاركان اللي على فكره كان قبل الشاب
في نفس القاعده التي قصفتها مسيرات
ايرانيه من ميليشيات مواليا لايران وهذه
رساله واضحه ان الرساله هي ان ايران تريد
ان ترسل رساله لامريكا ولاسرائيل ان نحن
نملك قدرات لان لان ايضا ندفع المنطقه الى
حافه الهاويه اذا اردنا عبر وكلائنا
وايران كما ذكرتي بالفعل لا تواجه بشكل
مباشر خصومه ولكن عقيده ايران تقاتل خارج
اراضيها وليس وليس هي التي تبادر ايضا
ولكن
وحلفائهم الذين يبادرون هذه الرساله
لاسرائيل عندنا القدره هذه المسيرات تضرب
ايضا داخل اراضيكم اذا اردنا عبر وكلائنا
وكذلك عندنا القدره لانه
ما شعرنا بانه هناك
يعني يثير السؤال عن
هناك استراتيجيه واضحه
للولايات المتحده في تعاملها مع ايران
نفس الوقت يحدث ما يحدث الان في سوريا
بالنسبه لايران خاصه بعد فشل الاتفاق
النووي او انسحاب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعززت القناعه لدى القياده
العليا بايران بان هذا الطرف غير جدير
بالثقه هامش الثقه يكاد يكون مفقود في
العلاقه بين ايران والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والاستراتيجيه الايرانيه منذ
الثوره الاسلاميه والى اليوم بتفاوت محدود
تقوم على هامش عدم الثقه بين
ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المساله الاخرى ان الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه
ترتبط بشكل اساسي اتجاه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ترتبط بصوره اساسيه بموضوع
اسرائيل والتهديد الاسرائيلي والدعم
الامريكي للولايه الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل
لذلك فالمواجهه مع اسرائيل هي في واحد من
اطراف فيها مواجهه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
من طاقه
الدقيقتين بقيت لي اريد ان اسال كلا منهما
الى اين ترون دكتور شايجي ابداء معك يعني
هل نحن
نقترب من مواجهه امريكيه ايرانيه
على الصعيد اوسع يعني
وصلنا 15 سنه
15 سنه نكرر لا مواجهه لا حرب امريه بين
امريكا واسرائيل وايران هناك تصعيد محكوم
بسقف لو ان تنسي
توتر منخفض
التصعيد منخفض الوتيره ومسيطر عليه ولكن
ايران الان ترى انها عندها فرصه عندها
نافذه يمكنها من خلالها ان تعيد النظر
لاهميتها ودورها وبرنامجها النووي يمكن
الاداره الامريكيه تعيد التفكير مع
الاوروبيين بمقاربه مختلفه وهذا ما تطمح
اليه ايران بان يكون هناك في اتفاق نووي
يمكنها ان تستفيد منه وترفع الحصار عنها
ما رايك اقرب اعتقد انه لا يمكن اسقاط
احتمال المواجهه خاصه مع التطور الذي حدث
على البرنامج النووي الايراني البرنامج
النووي الايراني ليس هو حتى مقارنه بالسنه
الماضيه وتيره التهديد تتصاعد التطور
بالبرنامج النووي يتصاعد التهديد
الاسرائيلي يتصاعد ولذلك لا يمكن ان نسقط
خيار المواجهه لكن
النقطه الاساسيه ان الكل يدرك تبعات
المواجهه وربما يكون ذلك هو ما يمنع
حدوثها الدكتوراه مصمدي البحث الاولى في
مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في الشان
الايراني اشكرك جزيلا واشكرك طبعا الدكتور
عبدالله الشايجي استاذه العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه الكويت
شكرا لكم وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام نلتقي
باذن الله في حلقه جديده من ما وراء الخبر
في
[موسيقى]